comme tous les jours depuis plus de dix
ans c'est le même rituel pour ali
restaurateurs dalle kabaria réception
des dons alimentaires organisation des
tâches
objectif sortir un repas complet destiné
aux nécessite de la capitale une
véritable course contre la montre pour
ce chef d'entreprise qui a décidé après
la révolution d'offrir chaque année un
repas pour permettre au plus grand
nombre de rompre le jeûne en ce mois de
ramadhan une initiative devenue une
tradition mais qui a dû s'adapter cette
année avec la crise ducobu 19 cette
année nous avons dû commencer à
travailler 25 jours avant le ramadan on
a commencé à distribuer des repas ceux
qui travaillent dehors aux familles les
plus démunies aux étudiants subsahariens
que ce soit dans la maison dans les
foyers car ce sont des personnes qui ont
très peu de moyens ou qui ne peuvent pas
sortir de cette année à cause du
coronavirus on a multiplié nos
livraisons
il y a même des familles entières qui
viennent nous voir des fois des familles
qui n'ont rien du tout à manger à la
tête de cette brigade de bénévoles un
chef qui chaque année met son temps et
son savoir faire au service des
nécessiteux un engagement qui a pris
cette année une toute autre tournure
bonjour chef on a convenu aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui au menu série épices et rick
salade de poivrons et cailles rôties
qu'est ce qui a changé pour vous cette
année il ya beaucoup de choses qui ont
changé cette année on a dû travailler
beaucoup plus car la demande est plus
importante
on a commencé directement avec plus de
700 repas et maintenant avec le ramadan
on dépasse facilement les mille et on
attend même les 1200 repas par jour où
on a plus de nourriture à distribuer
alors je me mets à cuisiner quelque
chose rapidement pour ne laisser
personne
comme chaque jour depuis dix ans ce sont
pas moins de mille repas qui sont
distribués avec la crise du coronavirus
la crise sanitaire a laissé place à une
réelle crise sociale qui attire de plus
en plus de personnes des chômeurs des
mères isolées et des familles
nécessiteuses des étudiants subsahariens
ou de simples voyageurs
il se donne comme tous les jours rendez
vous chez ali avant le coucher du soleil
alors là vous commencez à la
distribution
là on vient de commencer la distribution
est en priorité les étudiants
subsahariens car ils viennent de loin et
on veut leur permettre de rentrer
rapidement chez eux et surtout parce
qu'ils sont de passage chez nous comme
vous pouvez voir le premier groupe
d'étudiants vient d'arriver lui par
exemple vient chercher à manger pour six
personnes
bienvenue
3 4 5 6 2 on n'a pas de fonds n'a pas
n'y a pas de famille ici et puis vous
voyez et en plus aussi on a couru la
ville turin n'a pas d'argent
le peu qu'on nous envoie en copa gasquet
pour acheter on peut pas acheter de
nourriture c'est pourquoi on revient
tout le temps ici pour engager de plus
pour qu'on puisse garder l'argent qu'ils
envoient une fille voyez avec le
confinement et l'arrêt de nombreuses
activités
le nombre de nécessiteux a connu un bond
sur l'ensemble du territoire
creusant davantage cette fracture
sociale qui fragilise l'essor de cette
toute jeune démocratie où un quart de la
population vit sous le seuil de pauvreté
mais les initiatives citoyennes ne
mentent pas en tunisie tout comme à
lille sont nombreux à travers tout le
pays et apporter leur contribution pour
soulager ce qui semble avoir été
abandonnée par un système encore bien
fragile et timide né de la révolution de